hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The Last
of Us okay I'm too excited to say
anything I'm gonna get right into it
we're going through this dilapidated
building filled with fungal spores that
would cause horrific zombie
transformations and I'm not sure if
there's anything that I could find in
here because there's a lot of rooms that
I can just wander in them I'm assuming
that there would be some scavenge Abul
excuse me baby how you doing okay how do
I crouch oh boy
how do okay circle is Crouch Oh press r2
to focus girls hearing focus is here
whoa what the damn you got some good
hearing whoa
sneak up on the infected and grab them
by pressing triangle
alright strangle so I can strangle the
infected I didn't think that a fungally
infected human would be very worried
about okay how am I gonna deal with this
oh that is grody what do I do about that
we sneak by them can I sneak by him
maybe I should turn off my light yeah I
can see him I don't need a focal my
hearing let's just quietly carefully
move on just move on and avoid them
completely because I've heard from the
gameplay that fighting more than one is
never a good idea I'm guessing that a
bite from a zombie in this game might be
super lethal exceptionally lethal oK
we've got here
bullets yay I scavenge something is
everybody proud of me I found something
okay what was it was reload but r100
something else more bullets oh wait no
health
that okay so anyway there was a
staircase somewhere over here yeah okay
let's go up here and completely avoid
any of those dastardly bastards okay
have we exited the spore area I think we
have there one last obtainable good
around here press square to attack what
happened oh oh oh no oh lordy no don't
go oh wow
I'll punch you today oh yeah what's up
son
tink you know this you handle this yeah
yeah we're now will Jin brutal alright
so that was not good I points to candy
bar I'll point you [ __ ] I can't even how
do I get that triangle let's head back
into the city nom nom nom restore health
okay so apparently I buy from an
infected may not be lethal but maybe
just not those effect note to brother
all right
no to brother I may not be too much on
this we were so close sitting outside
the walls knowing never see inside okay
um take care mark oh there's a note from
me to me I should have mentioned to you
come to the zone this is really hard to
read with you when I had the chance now
it's too late okay
alright so it's a note of regret so
anyway we're moving forward um that's
the one thing that I will not be
focusing on this game are the notes and
collectibles um those you'll just have
to find out for yourself because I need
to keep this moving at a generally good
place so I will try my best to keep
going forward
ooh some fresh air yep better than
fungally infected air
in all the city nodejs bill to get you
some of them air fresheners leave
they weren't expired that'd be a good
idea yeah expired by about 20 years man
I really wonder like it seriously is
curious to me how they could keep order
in any sort of semblance twenty years
after a zombie apocalypse I mean I know
humans are highly ingenuity to do but
still infection seems highly viral viral
viral and I think we're still trying to
head after Robert it wasn't that our
objective or what were we trying to do
here
climb up on something forward NX ok I
sorted out the controls to so I'm gonna
do be doing much might fell down she's
it geese we're gonna have to jump it
watch this baby Herbert would you rare
oh boy okay I was gonna I was gonna jump
it I just you you're you're too much of
a baby to jump it I was gonna get it
hombre whatever whatever lady I got it
it's just I really like Tony okay we're
gonna pass it like this I really like
the way the slow started this game the
very slow pacing because a lot of games
like that you see today especially those
that are story driven are just always I
think I can handle it
who she's so strong are always just like
BAM right into the action just Boom Bang
is shooting shooting a million times but
this one very takes its time to
establish a setting is like it's like
I'm like I've said this before but this
is a lot like a movie in that it takes
time to set up the characters the plot
the setting get you immersed in the
story
yeah well bet babe man your ass baby
let's move Hamas you today baby ABBA oh
my got it how do I babe oh my god I
don't know oh girl I'm alone and scared
okay how do I do this
I really well I'm a gun no put away my
gun
jump swoosh what am i doing I'm so
scared I'm all alone
seriously I'm kind of curious what it
would what the hell do I do
what about what am I doing here what am
I doing here
am i there stupid am i there stupid the
answer would be yes I am the stupid
can't figure it out too dumb
way too dumb fart do too dumb maybe that
pipe
is that what I do now oh my god this is
embarrassing
this is really embarrassing okay let me
take a second here oh okay alright that
should have been really really really
really really really obvious but I'm too
stupid seriously that that took me an
embarrassingly long time to figure out
you don't want to know how long I was
off camera doing that
alright let's shut up and you move on
our way okay baby I for me make sure
there ain't any soldiers around it yeah
I'd be bad odd hey Tavish shoot them all
there was this really interesting story
or book or something that I read or saw
that explained how quickly a nature
would reclaim what humans of building
this is just 20 years later and you can
already see things are just dilapidated
falling apart like lay the things that
human build especially today aren't
meant to last forever they really aren't
and it would seem like counterintuitive
duh how much effort we put into the
buildings that we make but they really
it would not take long this whole the
thing that I read or saw I can't
remember what it was really explained it
in good detail a punch DMO I'll punch
you ever thing she's gonna go on a
punching spray is there anything in here
that I could eat some
food no oh man little man oh hello no
soldiers none of robert's men yeah yeah
okay thank you
what was that that he was wrapping card
well let it make it more interesting
okay thank you little guy was that
really worth a whole ration card
I don't know how valuable those things
are but briefly how you doing today I
heard you got some work now right now
tell no it does it good look not now
hear me okay yeah
not now Terrence jeez okay so we're in
some sort of a slum area if for this
whole place wasn't a slum already Hey
stop giving me those mean looks you
touch it you buy it
okay all right you selling some sass
gotta buy some hello oh I bet I could
take them all Savchuk what do you think
you're going kalique sit back oh sorry
Tess didn't realize you two were
together good yeah that's right yeah
whatever whatever
I wonder who Tess is is she's got so
much Poland's there yeah I mean honestly
she seems like a total badass I could
tell that right from when I first saw
her but either way this whole area is
pretty cool I mean not that I'm not a
badass but I love strong female
characters and I'm not saying that in a
sarcastic way a lot of times stories
always like damsel in distress things
back
I mention that a lot when I was playing
dead space 3 because they really like
weakened um le as a character oh sorry
sorry sorry I'm just I'm [ __ ] around
over here talking about other girls I
doubt I'm looking for Robert he comes
through here half hour ago you went back
to the war is there now
okie dokie hanky buddy
alright you I'm just tagging along
besides the badass it's like yeah hi
thanks thanks for being nice to me by
the way any trouble ok I don't want any
trouble
look for the light Oh for the fireflies
all right come on test I ready lead your
way again it's you Dee oh this seems
chest high walls oh oh oh I know what
this means
let us through
you guys need to turn around and head
back if you know what's good for you
no thank you isn't with you we just want
Robert okay I don't want to do this yeah
turn the [ __ ] around and leave now
hey no need to use bad words you where
without Robert [ __ ] Oh bash your skull
unless you turn around and get your dumb
ass out of here [ __ ] this
BAM however damn ready
see I love badass female Kurtz yelling
I'm not trying to say like but it's just
sucks in gaming that there aren't many
of them they really like how do whoa
give me I bet if I get shot that'd be
bad I see you know I can't shoot first
[ __ ] oh my god shot it hurts so bad
there we go okay nut shot thank you me
no it was it oh come on he was mine just
because I was aiming totally to the left
of him oh it's all on oh we know you
still alive what the hell
Daisy dead now you dead now see low on
health okay
I can only carry one med kit really I
stood on Texas thank you Oh
- is my name Texas or am i from the
Titans yet all these guys Roberts good
at one thing waiting blank check
okie dokie I can't seem to oh here we go
there's some ammo
give me that thank you alright see ray
r1 yes ma'am
okay I'll help you you just do
everything for me I think she killed all
those guys also I saw from the trailers
I really like the way the blood works in
this game because it really does kind of
soak into fabrics drip down dankey boob
mmm oh you're so strong
alright let's see who this Robert is oh
no more chest high walls I'm just
getting ready that's like a theme in
gaming today chess high walls always
cover based not saying that's a bad
thing but it's just a common theme
alright whoa whoa here Joel I thought
that might have been a gnome I get a
flashback from Oh No lots of chest high
walls strategically placed more Roberts
guys yep
how did you know - they're coming you
two of our guys died trying to take
tests out mmm guarantee that she and
Joel are on their way here right now to
get Robert okay we shouldn't have taken
this job not our call nice and quiet
tech spread out and make sure no one's
creeping around in here okay how about
like Tess right behind you
worried about that I'm gonna get oh I'm
gonna get this one oh yeah oh yeah oh
gonna get him good damn go stab him in
his boy good go to get it I probably
shouldn't be shouting as I'm drop well
drag all string all yay got him I
probably shouldn't be celebrating the
death of someone but it's game right
it's game okay anyway back to badass
mode okay let's see we got guys in there
I don't know complain again who's down
on Jordan Street okay Joel just showed
up with
about five six all in handcuffs okay let
me guess
fireflies yep they lined them up against
the wall and bang bang bang we just
executed all of them okay an error has
occurred I've been signed out of the
PlayStation Network Oh No okay I got a
cousin sure how do I get these guys
idiot thinks he's gonna save the world
hope he's alright he's probably not just
just being honest with you okay how do I
get in here how do I jump over this you
didn't hear a thing you didn't hear a
ding dong damn thing yeah just turn look
at that wall
it's totally the only thing that's
important right you didn't see anything
oh okay thanks Tess all right we got a
key here get the key for the warehouse
excuse me do you have any ammo sir
please okay it was another guy in there
wasn't there oh no that was Tess okay
never mind she was being much smarter
than I was okay full on health and I
don't have any med kits though so where
do I go can I focus my hearing in to
find any items is that a thing can I do
that probably not okay
anyway hello excuse me Robert
need to speak with you for a moment
you're low on ammo look for other
strategies to survive I agree hello Tess
you're kind of all up in my business are
you comfortable there okay good Oh
actually that's really interesting the
way the cover works I'm kind of covering
over it's interesting luck we'll find
him hmm
grab the bottle okay so arc thro l1 what
hear that oh the bottle everybody check
it out immediately everybody drop what
you're doing and go find whatever the
source of the noise was oh hello you're
nearby ancient
okay so we got this one guy here another
guy whoa whoa whoa whoa buddy whoa whoa
what the hell did you just see me
what was that what happened there ah no
please don't blame don't oh god it hurts
oh wait those ammo I need it I need that
I need that scuse me thank you thank you
thank you as I crawl away very slowly
you didn't see anything like a shadow in
the night so damn stealthy so damn
stealthy ha my mom wears on me oh my god
he shot me through that window holy crap
I didn't even notice and seriously the
gameplay in terms of combat is unlike
anything I've ever seen before and I
probably totally balls that up I only
got shot once so so I'm doing just fine
but this is seriously awesome I've heard
the day I was smart in this game it has
really cool I had no idea how I even got
there oh oh boy don't notice yeah
beautiful thank you ah where why how
like I've never been playing a game that
actually felt like what it would be like
cuz if I was actually in a fire flight I
would have no idea what's going on and
maybe it's just because I have no
training at all but I have no idea
what's going on is there someone up
there can I focus my hearing here no one
huh I can't see anyone through the walls
or maybe that's just cuz I can't hear
them oh hello hello sir how you doing
you're not gonna find anyone cuz you're
so stupid
don't hit the paint cancer Wow
thank you yes you're so awesome you're
the best love you forever long time
thank you Tessa's awesome
I want Tess to be with me all of the
times okay we got another bottle here
but I don't really think that's gonna
help me now considering that I was
stupid and alerted everyone to my
position I don't have many bullets left
I really got to not use all of my
bullets
man there's two ways out of this oh
hello I'm gonna sneak up behind you so
good oh wait no Tess get um get him Tess
you're the best I believe in you I
believe in you Tess Tess look out cuz no
okay wait hang on no I'm gonna ambush
him my name is you grab him grab him
punch him in the face yeah yeah what's
up what's up now you got nothing you got
nothing
hey hey baby did you see the way I
punched him more people we don't need
Lois down yeah
yeah I am right yeah yeah come on Joe
where there doctor this way let us do
this okay so we need to pull this chain
here and then we're gonna have a huge
battle with a bunch of people on the
docks maybe also I just want to admit
part of the graphics very cool to see a
non bald main character and Tess
actually have real hair that's something
in game that always bugged me like all
of them all the enemies are just bald is
that Robert can I kill him that's a lot
of guys [ __ ] let's go grab Pacey on
okay seriously that is a lot of guys out
there
no one saw a thing okay so I just need a
hello baby you need my protection oh no
you don't yeah cuz you're a badass
contacts in the north by us you don't
see a damn thing
no you know nothing you can see anything
you Shawn nothing you didn't see a
middle-aged man just kind of wandering
through the area we don't see it ha ha
oh okay oh yeah that did not go well
ah okay all right so he's down no one
heard a thing right everyone is Oh
scheisse scheisse crap I did this badly
okay sir excuse me I'm gonna need you to
remain calm it's not an emergency you
don't need to worry about anything
that's going on right now where'd you
come from where are these people even
coming from
TAS can you help me please
that guy doesn't even have a gun oh he's
being very smart about it - where's our
- while aiming to shoulder switch oh
whoa
cool hey buddy you want to not ah pip
photo you don't own up aren't you your
dad punch you I'm just gonna paunch
everybody
hey eyes got a gun I just having fun
with this my gosh old alley boom
headshot okay I'm getting slightly
better with this Hey oh my god oh god
yeah damn it I'm so bad if I had a
keyboard mouse I'd be so much gooder
I probably now you all saw my dead space
playthrough i was not not in any way
okay I'm gonna charge this guy rawr rawr
are you all ready go will bat I don't
pick that up
give me how do I switch weapons you'll
make who's sorry your mother make your
mother sorry that you've chosen this
lifestyle
sir-sir what would your family think of
you right now yeah I do
whoa yes yes I do you do - I'm gonna
come up there and punch the [ __ ] out of
you uh-huh pouch pouch Oh bat punch dead
detonated a brick I'll take that
how do I throw that how do I throw that
ha ha ow
how bad badness now get him okay I got
like I said I'm not the best to
PlayStation 3 gamers so excuse please
excuse any hormonal Pancho
bunchy how we my head how that really
hurt but I'm doing okay because I'm so
tough Hess is just standing there like
Jesus Christ what the what the hell are
you doing man
you're embarrassing yourself okay I
picked up a brick I don't remember how
to throw it how do I cycle through my Oh
like that okay
I'm gonna break the [ __ ] out of someone
hi Robert
ah brick with your name on it you want
to come over here and Robert must have
run in there let's go okay I got my
brick you got your gun
you gonna stick with gun I'll take the
brick take the brick I like the brick
brick is nice brick about what some of
this brick alright alright Josh you want
to Brooke nürnberg am I gonna get a
brick baby you got this I got my brick
at the ready you just want to talk
Robert yeah sure [ __ ] nothing to talk
about
put your gun down I'm gonna trick you in
the head
go [ __ ] yourself he's running ok Ryeon I
must stop and look at everything Joel so
Betty sweetie
ok all right come on he ran in here Joel
who's Joel am i Joel is that me is my
name Joel I can't even remember what my
name is hi hi sir littering is a crime
excuse me you seem to not be following
the rules you see we have won the fight
we killed all your friends and ergo you
should give up you should just give up
lie down Joel I went the wrong way ok
this way sir sir I hear you knocking
things over there's not good behavior
hello robert
yes Joe
know our feelings right none at all do
it we missed you
look whatever it is you heard it ain't
true okay I just want to see sons you
want to tell us where the guns are yeah
sure but it's complicated
Hey look all right just hear me out on
this I got mad [ __ ] how quick stop stop
stop oh quit your squirming you were
saying I sold him excuse me I didn't
have much of a choice I owe someone you
owed us
I say you bet on the wrong horse I just
need more time just give me a week you
know I might have done that if you
hadn't tried to [ __ ] kill me come on
one who has our guns
I can't you just give me a couple THM em
has our guns
it's the fireflies I hold the fireflies
what okay they're basically all dead who
witness just go in there finish him off
we get the guns who do you say come on
and [ __ ] those fireflies let's go get
him that is a stupid idea
well now what we go get our merchandise
back how I don't know we explain it to
them look let's just go find a Firefly
we won't have to look very far there you
go
Queen Firefly why are you here
business you're looking so hot where's
Robert
I needed him alive the guns he gave you
they weren't his to sell I want them
back doesn't work like that test the
hell it doesn't
I paid for those guns you want them back
you're gonna have to earn them how many
cards are we talking about I don't give
a damn about ration cards
I need something smuggled out of the
city you do that I'll give you your guns
back
Benson how do we know you got him we're
here the military's been wiping you guys
out you're right about that
I'll show you the weapons I got to move
what's gonna be I want to see those guns
follow me we gotta get out of here now
oh man I just love love love love this
game it's paint such a cruel picture on
the reality of this situation it's just
so brutal and the way there's just no
emotion when they were beating the [ __ ]
out of Robert it's it's just so
delectable I'm not saying it's good that
what they did it's good that the story
is so good at portraying it it's just so
enriching it's such a crazy awesome
experience but anyway I'm all out of
time for this part so I'm gonna save my
game which I haven't already which I
probably should a long time ago because
I might have lost everything but anyway
still it's just this is this is
absolutely awesome I love it it's gonna
be a great game god I'm so excited as
fantastic Oh
okay all right we saved new save data
okay
saving I haven't saved in an hour that
I've been playing okay so anyway hope
you guys are enjoying the series
seriously plant play this game by it's
worth it so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see
in the next video bye-bye
Jenna
really what
Oh
dude